all right so if you haven't heard
jennifer lopez and alex rodriguez have
announced their breakup in a today
exclusive
apparently there's a 1.8 million dollar
engagement ring that has yet to be
returned and i'm waiting for jennifer
lopez to do her best anthony edwards
impression and say of alex rodriguez i
don't know who that is that's what i
can't wait to have happen all right so
in honor of that and in lieu of any
better ideas for this segment on a
fairly slow thursday
the most memorable
breakups in nfl history not involving
1.8 million dollar
diamond rings miles give me one
okay well the first one i think is very
obvious and that is tom brady and bill
belichick and look this was very
important because it just resulted in
the most recent super bowl that we saw
and i think when you're together for as
long as tom brady and bill belichick
were together that's a really weird
thing to see tom brady go to a different
uniform first of all tom brady for my
entire football consciousness had been
the patriots quarterback and then to win
a super bowl with the next team that's
that's wild man that's so wild to me
uh for me it's it's brett favre and the
green bay packers the way that whole
thing went down i still believe to this
day
that the packers went to brett favre in
february of 2008 and said to him we need
to know now what you're going to do this
year because they knew if they pressed
him then
he would say i'm retiring they knew him
well enough to know how he how he ebbs
and flows and comes and goes and in
february march april may june he wants
nothing to do with it when july rolls
around and that smell that smell of the
grass late summer gets in the air that's
when he's interested in planet that's
exactly what happened it's exactly what
happened and it set the stage for a
horrific divorce and he ultimately ended
up back with the vikings after a year
with the jets and i remember that first
game at lambeau field every time he was
on the field he was booed he was booed
he was booed that to me was a
ridiculously ugly and avoidable breakup
it was and i don't necessarily remember
it as well as you do of course i mean
you were older than me then so and you
still are now but i think that this that
was something that could have maybe been
avoided yes i know uh until you die um
but anyway let's just move on to my next
pick which is going to be the cleveland
the city of cleveland and art model and
i can't imagine why i would possibly say
this right let me tell you something
here mike
the cleveland browns were my birthright
okay
i was in the womb in the dog pound and
for ardmodell to take my team away from
me and put it in baltimore where they
then won two super bowls all right my
the first two rule i remember was from
1999 with the greatest show on turf the
next one i remember was the one from
2001 where the patriots won because my
mother would not let me watch the ravens
possibly win a super bowl because that's
how horrible it was for our family so
i gotta just say art model man
not happy with you all right and i and
you know rest in peace and all that but
the fact that my team my birthright team
got taken away and the browns were
atrocious basically for my entire
football consciousness until last year
boy
it stings just stings
i'm glad you threw in the rest in peace
i mean you said everything but art model
go to hell oh wait you're already there
good lord all right uh we're we don't we
don't we don't know that he's there i
personally believe there is no hell but
that's a different topic all together
all right jerry jones jimmy johnson
their divorce in early 94 and it wasn't
that early in 94 it was in like late
march early april a very late juncture
of the offseason to be replacing your
head coach
but
for whatever reason they couldn't get
along miles and it's a shame because
they may have won four in a row if they
could have found a way to get those two
egos to coexist
they could have but then they still did
win a super bowl with barry switzer not
that i remember it but you know i think
that that's still
awesome for that particular team that
you can still say you won another
championship but who knows what would
have happened if jimmy johnson had been
able to stay there and they could
co-exist
let me mention one more randy moss had
not won but two ugly divorces with the
vikings first they abruptly trade him
after the 2004
season i think it was and then when they
traded for him in 2010 remember he got
fired because he said of the food in the
locker room i wouldn't feed this crap to
my dog
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports